it's impossible to talk about the krogan
without going into detail about the
genophage
so this lore video is going to be a bit
of a combo platter that dives into the
backstory of the krogan
as well as the biological weapon
designed to stop them
if you're into mass effect and want to
see more of these types of videos be
sure to give the video a like
and with that let's dive into it
the krogan have been around for a long
time their species earliest ancestors
date back to the time of the protheans
for more on the protheans check out our
first mass effect lore video
anyways the krogan originate on a planet
called tachanka the planet is filled
with vicious predators ironically the
krogan probably were not originally
one of them given that they have wide
set eyes they typically denote animals
that are prey
and need to have a wider field of view
to notice predators
but the krogan evolved to become the
dominant species of tichonka
likely sped along by their unnaturally
fast reproduction rate female krogan
would typically produce a
thousand fertilized eggs a year
additionally
much like earth's camels krogan evolved
to have massive humps on their back
designed to store
water and nutrients allowing them to go
for long periods of time without the
need to eat or drink
and on top of all of that krogan have
secondary and tertiary organs as well as
an accelerated healing factor
for example krogan have two hearts so if
one is damaged the other can take over
and keep the krogan alive while the
first one begins healing
these extra organs and healing factor
make krogan near unstoppable juggernauts
that live for a
very long time like mass effect
andromeda's drack who is 1400 years old
the extra organs also informs the
krogan's vocabulary you may notice that
several krogan throughout the mass
effect games refer to bravery as someone
having
quads that mirror is our earthly
expression of saying someone who's
courageous has balls
krogans say quads because they have four
testicles
given their nature krogan developed a
society that values strength and is
composed of individual clans each of
which is overseen
by an overlord there's also a spiritual
element to croak in society as well
with each clan possessing a shaman to
provide spiritual guidance and krogan
growing up by performing specific rites
of passage
like the other species we've talked
about in these lore videos the krogan
became the dominant species of their
world conquering tuchanka and eventually
like most sentient milky way species
evolving to the point of achieving
industrialization this briefly led to a
period of architectural
and artistic advancement but it was
short-lived
as the krogan had evolved to be an
aggressive species in order to survive
on tichonka
they possessed an innate bloodlust for
seeking out challenges
but with industrialization no other
species on tachanka could provide
that so they decided to fight each other
instead
by 1900 bce over 4 000 years prior to
the events of mass effect 1
the krogan had developed nuclear weapons
and individual clans entered all-out
nuclear war
the conflict pretty much destroys
tichonka plunging the planet into a
nuclear winter
for 2 000 years the remaining krogan
clans struggled to survive
continuing to fight one another over the
planet's now scarce amount of resources
and that's the state the solarians found
them in in adce
okay let's pivot really quick remember
our last mass effect lore video the one
about the first contact war
that conflict can be traced back to the
citadel activating dormant mass relays
and accidentally discovering the raknai
which led to the rachni wars and one ce
the lore of the krogan ties back to that
story too in one
ce the citadel council is solely
composed of the asari and salarians the
former provides wisdom while the latter
contributes leadership and scientific
research
so while both have armies neither one
has the military might to counter the
rachni
a surprisingly intelligent and highly
aggressive insect-like species
that breeds quickly and originated on a
dangerous planet allowing them to evolve
as to survive
harsh environments the asari and
salarians come from home worlds where a
war-like mentality was not
necessary to become the dominant species
and so they are ill-prepared to stop the
raknai
this is where the krogan come in upon
discovering the krogan the solarians
noticed that they have a surprisingly
similar evolutionary history to the
rachni
making them ideally suited for fighting
the insect-like invaders
the solarians decide to step in and help
the krogan gifting them technology and
weapons the krogan were centuries away
from developing for themselves
one such piece of tech is the shroud
which stabilizes tuchanka's atmosphere
and allows more of the planet to become
livable the solarians also helped the
krogan expand their population to new
planets
once far less dangerous than tachenka
giving the krogan room to quickly expand
their numbers once more
this of course was not all done out of
kindness
the solarians hoped to influence the
krogan transforming them into a near
unstoppable army that would side with
the solarians and asari
against the rachni and the plan worked
not only do the krogan breed fast enough
to match
numbers with the raknai their unique
physiology allows them to endure the
harsh conditions of the rakhine
homeworld
by 300 ce the krogan stop the rachni's
advancement
push the insect-like species back to
their home world and then eradicate them
as a reward the krogan get a monument on
the citadel and a place in the milky way
government
no seed at the council but their
ambassador gets a lot of sway as the
krogan fulfilled the military force the
citadel council had been lacking
the galaxy views the krogan as heroes
there's only
one problem in uplifting the krogan the
salarians basically put the krogan in
the same
spot they were in prior to nuclear war
devastating tachanka
the krogan are rapidly expanding and
have no challenge to curb their growth
only now they have the technology to
expand to more
worlds and find other species to fight
instead of fighting each other
over the next 400 years the krogan
spread across the milky way forcibly
claiming already inhabited worlds
noting the public's growing concern that
the krogan are becoming a threat similar
to the rachni
the council begins creating a
contingency program a group of the
galaxy's best solarian special task
group operatives
anasari huntresses this military group
would be founded in 693
ce it would be called the special
tactics and reconnaissance branch of the
citadel or
spectres in 700 ce the krogan finally
reach and begin taking over lucia
an asari colony the council steps in
saying that the krogan have overstepped
the good faith they
earned when driving at the rachni the
krogan ambassador at the time
overlord kardak just walks out of the
council chambers daring the council to
try and stop the krogan
the council responds by sending in the
specters kicking off another war
called the krogan rebellions though the
specters proved to be devastatingly
effective allowed to use any act of war
they deem necessary
the council runs into the same problem
they did with the rachni the krogan
breed
too quickly for the hundreds killed
thousands take their place
each year in desperation the council
turns to another species the turians
unlike the more democratic species of
the milky way the turians had developed
into a hierarchy
one heavily defined by military service
the turians entered the krogan
rebellions and proved to be a
substantial threat
prompting the krogan to respond by
bombing turian colonies with weapons of
mass destruction this infuriates the
turians who decide the krogan must be
dealt with
permanently 10 years later however the
krogan are
still winning so the turians turned to
the solarians who had been developing a
biological weapon
designed to reduce krogan numbers by
infecting the grogan with a genetic
mutation
that would lower the probability of
viable pregnancies
the solarians had been designing the
weapon known as the genophage as
a means of deterrent peacefully stopping
the krogan from waging war over
fear of the genophagious release the
turians were still angry over what the
krogan had done to them however
though the solarians and a few
subordinate turians
attempted to stop the genophage's
deployment the turian hierarchy went
ahead anyway
utilizing the shroud to spread the
genophage throughout all of tachanka
the effects were immediate mutating the
krogans that only one in a thousand
offspring would survive childbirth 90
years later in 800 ce
the krogan realized that they cannot
maintain the numbers to combat both the
spectres
and the turians and surrender
100 years after that in 900 ce the
turians get a seat on the citadel
council for their efforts in the krogan
rebellions
the turians take on the krogan's
previous role of policing citadel space
which will ultimately lead to the first
contact war
and again we've got a video about that
key moment in mass effect history too
some of the best turian soldiers like
sarin also become specters
the krogan still suffering the effects
of the genophage begin to lose the drive
to survive as a people
believing their species is just going to
go extinct anyway
as a result many krogan depart to chanka
and their respective clans and take on
solo work as bounty hunters or
bodyguards across the galaxy
though many wish to reverse the effects
of the genophage the krogan do not
possess scientific knowledge on par with
the solarians
the genophage just becomes a staple of
who the krogan are
with individual clans disagreeing in how
to combat the mutation
and whether it's even worth it to try
the one thing that all clans agree to is
that fertile female krogan are to be
protected
at all costs other than that the species
as a whole is really just
waiting to completely die out and that's
the way things stay until the events of
mass effect about
1200 years later so when you pick up
mass effect legendary edition
hopefully you now have a better idea as
to why there is a statue honoring the
krogan
on the citadel but why the krogan as a
whole aren't highly regarded by the rest
of the milky way
and why many krogan have fatalistic
attitudes the genophage is one of the
many thoroughline stories of the mass
effect trilogy alongside the rachni war
gethwar and several other conflicts
where details aren't black and white
were the turians on the right for
deploying the genophage and were the
solarians even in the right to even make
it in the first
place we'd love to hear what you think
in the comments below
and be sure to subscribe for more mass
effect lore videos like this one
you